what's more likely rookie edition let's
get into it quarterback more likely to
see the field first in 2020 tuatanga
vilo in miami or justin herbert in l.a
well you know i think justin herbert's
the more talented prospect i certainly
liked him more coming out in the draft
but i think when it comes to this i'm
going to go with tua on this
conversation here you know
one
i think the the chargers seem pretty
steadfast on they'd like to play tyrod
taylor for this year and play this
certain style of football uh where
they're going to kind of can run the
ball you know be high percentage passes
and then they get a great defense you
know the miami dolphins they're they're
total like you said already in this hour
it's a rebuild mode this is really just
the start of it ryan flores has finally
got some guys in there to be excited
about and here we go so and we know what
ryan fitzpatrick is and i just think the
clamoring and the fan base and
everything like that uh i think if tua
can just show that he's you know pretty
close to 100 or a hundred percent i i
just think we'll see him first uh before
justin herbert
yeah and two is already under contract i
believe justin herbert has not i haven't
heard that
rash of signings as we get closer and
closer to the start of training camp and
here's the thing to the extent that
players uh first of all to the extent
that you're getting your guaranteed
money if that's the end result of
discussion between the nfl and the nfl
pa most of the rookies taken in the
first couple of rounds have fully
guaranteed contracts for their first
seasons and also for the guys in round
one the bulk of your compensation is a
gigantic signing bonus it's a small
salary it's a gigantic signing bonus but
we're seeing more and more of these
rookies agreed you agree though all
right you're going you're going to it
too though you agreeing yeah yeah i
think i think to it yeah i think two i
mean it's a given joe burrow is going to
start from week one in cincinnati i it
you know brett favre has made the
argument that jordan loves should be
used in specialty packages almost like a
taysom hill in green bay but uh i think
between tua and herbert it's going to be
two up before herbert i think they
really want to give tyrod taylor a
chance to show what he can do yeah
best the best help around him that he's
arguably ever had in his career right
all right the receiver more likely to
dominate as a number two option jerry
judy in denver behind cortland sutton or
cd lamb in dallas behind amari cooper
you know i'm gonna go with cd lamb here
first off i like cd lamb more as a
player i i did coming out in the draft
and that's not to disrespect jerry judy
i know he's hell of a player too but cd
lam to me is one of those guys that
first off doesn't need a system you know
that's where i thought he was special he
can he can catch a slant and make three
people miss and run for a 60-yard
touchdown you know he can he can be
covered and catch a 50-50 ball or beat
people down the sidelines and just beat
them with speed so i like his skill set
and overall talent level and i really
look at it as like he'll be a true true
number two like amari cooper's gonna be
one but he will be weapon number two in
the past game where in denver i think
there's some other people that could
take away from jerry judy a little too
they have a special tight end noah fan
has got the talent to be one of the best
in the league and then you got a guy
like kj hamler too who they drafted in
the second round who's got like three
rockets up his butt so i just i guess
what i'm saying is i think there's a
little bit more of uh you know a group
there in denver that could take away
from judy's stats a little as well
and the broncos seem to be hell-bent on
getting jerry judy and i wonder if they
banked on cd lam being available at
number 15 because i think you and i both
agree cd lam's got the better potential
and when you start talking about
receivers getting drafted later than
they thought they should get drafted
that's that michael thomas chip on the
shoulder potential right where a guy may
be even better it goes back to randy
moss in 98 the longer you linger as a
receiver and you get upset about it and
you buckle down and you focus and you're
determined to prove everyone wrong it's
another reason i agree with you i think
c.d lam is going to be the more
impactful player and that leads to the
next one because henry ruggs iii was the
first receiver drafted i think an an
extra burden comes with that
is it more likely that he rejuvenates
derek carr
or that henry ruggs becomes the next
james jet really fast guy hey don't diss
james jet like that james jett was still
productive he was i didn't come up let's
not knock james jet right let's let's
say the next let's say the next darius
hayward bay okay that's a better one
who never gets it done right what's more
like and he was a first round pick right
i mean i think darius hayward bay was
like a top 10 pick maybe if i remember
and was picked by the raiders yeah
before michael crabtree number seven in
2010 yeah somewhere in there right so um
you know this one's a tough one you know
i like rugs i certainly do i could see
him being maybe a little bit of a
straight line
runner disappointing that way
um
but hmm man i think
if you make me pick here i'm gonna say
he rejuvenates derek carr's career i am
i i think gruden
will have enough tricks and plays in his
playbook that even if henry ruggs
doesn't turn out to be the overall
polished receiver that we'd like him to
be and continue to grow in i think he'll
find a package for the guy just to be a
a weapon a la a tyree kill where yeah he
could run he just runs deep routes go
routes deep crosses reverses speed
sweeps and they'll make it happen that
way i was one year off
the oakland raiders made darius hayward
bay the seventh overall pick in 2009 the
49ers took michael crabtree at number 10
in 2009 but uh yeah uh hayward bay
really really fast and we know how the
raiders have been i mean i was stunned
although it's it's in character for the
organization i really was stunned that
they went with rugs there and it does
put a ton of pressure it does first
receiver taken and uh you know he's
going to be constantly compared to judy
right to lamb and uh and he's never been
the guy mike that's the other thing too
like it was never like oh he was the
number one guy right in alabama there's
going to be some adjustment there and
the other thing i'll say too his biggest
flaw is you know there were some games
where when you know in college he got
jammed you know he he had a problem
getting off of jam coverage he did and
you could see it actually would like
discourage him for the rest of the game
in some of those games where he
struggled like that so uh he's a very
interesting prospect to watch out there
is a little bit of a boom bust factor to
me with him
and and uh the issue
from a few weeks ago that weird thing
right with the leg yeah he had to get
the moving something and he got his leg
lacerated and it's like henry you got
money now right you pay for people to do
things that could create a physical risk
to you your body is your temple do what
you can to keep it safe until you go
into a football field and throw yourself
into harms
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports